this is a production of Cornell
University
so starting with a little background
Noah is a crowdsourced Network the
weather station owners share the weather
data through the network and provide to
us feedback and guidance on what we
should or should not be do doing what we
could do better weather data is
collected every 15 minutes and tabulated
and hourly and daily summaries we're
collecting precipitation temperature
relative humidity leaf wetness solar
radiation wind speed wind direction and
growers that purchase these weather
instruments now have the option of
getting soil moisture and soil
temperature sensors but we still haven't
put into place the API that will
actually pull that data in we need to go
to one minute data and we're going to be
doing that this fall sister stations in
the network are designated for missing
data to fill gaps so that we don't have
bizarre accumulated degree days and
things like that with a lot of missing
data or will extrapolate one our gaps in
our data the decision support tools are
primarily for IP on but we also have
some for crop production which is why
I'm here today to share those with you
and they are built obviously from that
weather data so a little bit more about
Noah's history it was created in 1996 by
Curt pet salt at that time he was the
vegetable IPM coordinator the New York
State IPM program originally it was an
association they charged membership fees
and today it's open access with
land-grant university partners and
grower Association partners initially we
started out with sensor and Campbell
instruments sensor was bought by
sensotronic those instruments went
obsolete today we're partnering with
rain wise incorporated for all of our
weather instrumentation for the most
part although we do have a number of
onset instruments in the network some of
you may be using the name brand hobo as
little data loggers onset is the company
that manufactures those we also pull in
National Weather Service Airport data
and we partner with state climatologist
nets currently right now our
when an only partner is the New Jersey
State Climatologist but we're working on
some other meza net partners initially
we were going out with our laptops and
manually downloading these data bring in
back creating messages putting those
messages on a system called kota phone
and growers could dial in to those and
get that message du jour about what was
going on what the IPM program thought
that people should be paying attention
to we switch to modems I'm glad to say
we've saved about eight thousand dollars
in operating costs by eliminating our
modems and phone lines so that was a big
savings which was important when Noah
was zero funded oh and I say Noah Don
said niwe and it's like potato potato
it's fine everything's good so if you
hear me say Noah just know that I am
talking about the same thing so today we
have a few stations that are still using
file transfer protocol but most are
using Internet Protocol to send the data
directly to a website a train wise we
scrape that data off their web into our
database and rain was has developed a
cellular data modem systems so for
growers who have a desire to have a
weather instrument but it's a very
remote location they don't have
broadband they can use the cellular data
option we're now up to 432 weather
stations last time I gave this talk a
month ago in Plant Pathology we had 428
so we're growing all the time just all
the time growing so that's pretty
exciting we have weather stations were
pulling data in in 23 States we have 10
member states and then grower members in
additional five other states that it
could swelled up when we have airports
in states that are neighboring a grower
owned weather instrument because we need
that sister data we need complementary
data so that we know that we're not
going to have outages
so open access real-time query based
decision support with built-in bio fix
in an interactive user interface this is
our current website built in 2009 I know
for the Millennials in the audience
you're going to be groaning oh my gosh
that's so old I know it's pretty much
geriatric now and we're trying to get
money to rebuild our website so far two
grants later no bites but will still
continue trying the blue menu at the top
pretty audience in Geneva I'll try to
use the cursor as a player so this blue
menu follows you throughout the website
and gets gives you access to all of the
tools and products on anh nua and up
here there's a kind of neat little
utility that I like it's a find the
National Weather Service weather
forecast for your location you just
enter your city state zip code and hit
go and it'll get you to that National
Weather Service page with forecast data
etc on this map which starts out here it
will save your location you know how it
is now if you don't disable location
services on your phone your phone always
knows where you are and so does noah it
knows where you are so the next time you
go in if you're in North Carolina that
map's going to Center on North Carolina
instead of New York State so we try to
do little things as we can to make the
end user experience more fun and
exciting every weather station has a
station page and on the station pages
basically the key is that there are
these quick links to the pest forecasts
that will give you the result for that
pest forecast or that tool right there
for today's date it defaults to the
current date and then here there are
some quick links to weather products
degree days hourly data etc so here's
newaz map the green icons on there are
the new aware that are owned primarily
by growers but some are owned by the
land grant in
to shun for instance Connecticut's land
grant Yukon they manage all of their
weather stations they have about 40 in
their network one in every County and
then some additional ones on grower
farms and in primarily their focus is
the turf and landscape industry with
those county-based instruments then if
you can see there the little air
airplane icons those are the airport
locations and then this map here shows
you the member states that are in purple
and then in orange are those states
where there are one or two maybe three
individual growers that have purchased a
weather station and are subscribing into
the newest system it's about two hundred
and ninety dollars a year for an
individual subscriber and if you're a
statewide member an unlimited number of
weather stations can connect to nua for
a fee of 1750 per year so that's
essentially our revenue stream you can
do the math and you can see that we
operate on something less than twenty
thousand dollars a year fairly limited
revenue stream but it's growing we've
got over four hundred and thirty
stations now so it's pretty exciting I
haven't shown this slide in my previous
seminars but I thought okay I'll show
this to you guys so this is where the
data is going how how it moves around so
we start with the weather station the
data goes to rain wise net we scrape it
off and following the black arrows goes
into our new a database which is at the
Northeast Regional Climate Center and
then pushes that data to the newest
server where it goes through a number of
tools and algorithms etc and then the
end user will access that anh nua
cornell.edu we also have some metadata
for quality control and that informs the
newest server location of the station
page for instance so that gives you you
know just gives you in a nutshell kind
of where what we're doing with cloud
computing and what we're we're moving
all of these data so how does nua or nua
fit the programs of the horticulture
section so obviously plant developing
mental models plant phenology models can
be developed into tools to inform
management decisions and I'll show you a
couple of these it during today's
seminar weather data can be used to
validate and implement horticulture
models and obviously the data and models
that are in nua can be used for research
teaching and extension so for instance
Greg I'm not going to no pressure here
Ian merwin used to use some of the new
Apple models for his teaching so I
didn't mean that to be in any way a plug
or if you know so giddy right okay there
you go so the idea was hey Julie you
really should tell people about nua you
should get the word out that is what my
group of state coordinators has been
telling me so these seminars I'm trying
to tell the Cornell community about nua
so that you're aware of this some of
these data could enrich your own
research programs and teaching programs
and I want to definitely stimulate
thinking about developing and utilizing
nua to benefit our agricultural and
horticultural commodities so I'm going
to now talk about what the predictive
tools are that are in nua increasingly I
oh up and they were called models
disease forecast models insect phenology
models increasingly now they're called
tools and for those of you who were kind
of in this arena it's not even precision
agriculture anymore it's being called
digital agriculture so increasingly
growers are utilizing this type of
technology in their crop production
practices so I'm going to spend a little
bit of time on pest forecast tools like
nothing more than this one slide just to
give you a flavor that here this is the
drop-down menu from the new Oh website
of what we currently have available this
menu has shrunk
because we've started combining into one
page onion models for instance are all
the disease models are all in one page
the grape models are all in one page it
just makes it a little bit easier for
the end user but we have 16 plant
disease tools 11 insect phenology tools
we're now providing 5 day forecasts and
details on past and current conditions
in most of our tools so the grower can
look forward five days and no they have
to plan to do some sort of intervention
on the farm and what we want growers to
be able to do is to assess risk learn
about IPM and get decision support
through nua the weather products I'm
going to spend a little more time on
because I think there are more relevant
to the horticulture arena where we're
looking at plant development we might be
wanting to know more about just growing
degree days and the tabulation of degree
days so we're currently tabulating
degree days for 12 based temperatures we
accumulate that value starting January
one March one april one and May one
primarily informed by the commodities
that we're working with so for instance
in apples which I know probably more
about than any of the other crops that
are that have tools on nua in Apple's
via basically the common tenet is that
there's no growth before march first and
we don't even bother looking at
accumulation of degree days before march
first well guess what climate change is
changing that and indeed we are getting
weird things going on before march first
now so the exciting thing is the degree
date calculator we had created a degree
day calculator in PHP
beyond our ancient website before the
one I'm showing you today and because
the programming language wasn't
compatible with the new system we didn't
get this degree too calculated
resurrected until this year so it's
really exciting to be able to use a
degree day calculator and once again so
a little bit about all of these various
degree days that are in nua so you might
say well why do you have just 12 based
temperatures the reason is that we're
already using these base temperatures
shown in this table for a number of
different tools in nua and so we use
that as our drop-down selection because
the algorithms are already built they're
already there a couple of these I want
to bring to your attention the seed corn
maggot 39 degrees Fahrenheit one and the
14.3 degrees centigrade one for brown
marmorated stink bug have no tools
associated with them at all there is no
brown marmorated stink bug developmental
model right now available but research
has shown that its base temperature for
development is 14.3 centigrade and so I
said okay well let's just put that in
New what people can then query that or
look at the tables for degree days
knowing that and basically make some
intuitive inferences or deductions from
the data as it's being calculated the
seed corn maggot one was developed
because my colleague can wise who works
with field crops has a newsletter and he
said Julie you know I'd love to be able
to calculate based degree days for base
39 Fahrenheit so that I can put the
information in my newsletter because I
know it when it gets to a certain point
seed corn maggot is at this stage and
then I alert the growers through my
newsletter and so he can look at that
for all the different locations across
New York put that in his newsletter now
so that's kind of
that's kind of maybe how things get
started they get rolling along just
because you know that there's a base
development of temperature there's a
model out there and somebody wants a
piece of it for all the rest of these
there is an actual tool in nua for them
and obviously for growing degree days
GDD that's just again also just the
degree date tables it's not going to say
expect lilac to be at this phenological
stage with this accumulation of GDD so
you know that's that's where I rely on
the faculty across Cornell and across
the reach of nua to say I'd love to have
a model that did this let's develop it
this is the degree day calculator and
this shows you essentially how all of
the tools on nua are built most of them
some of them are slightly different but
they all will have a little query on the
left hand side where you select the
state weather station the type of degree
day in this case I chose base 50 the
accumulation start date I allowed this
to default to January one and the end
date men you hit get report the model
starts out with a map so it starts out
with a map that way you don't have to
know the station name you can actually
look at the map and say okay
geographically this one's going to be
closest but from an altitude perspective
I think I'm going to select this other
one because the topography might might
be better with better match at that
other weather station location so the
map gives a little more flexibility than
just knowing the name of the weather
station location as soon as you hit get
report the wheel starts turning that
query is sent to the server and the
results page pops back up so this chart
builds and wherever you scroll your
mouse over the chart this pop-up box
will pop up and give you the actual data
for that particular point the chart
above again gives the past the current
and the five-day forecast out
the daily degree days base 50 and the
seasonal accumulation starting as my
query requested from January first and
you can see we started to get colder in
mid-september and yeah it's kind of
chilly now I had frost at my house last
night here's another way that you can
use weather data in hindsight gee I
think it got really cold on februari
14th this past winter and it was really
mild for a long time and indeed this
cold snap a number of people are
attributing to one of the big reasons
why we didn't have a lot of stone fruit
this year in New York so apricots
peaches nectarines sweet cherries could
have been significant with the flower
buds could have been significantly
damaged by this temperature event so if
you're looking at the daily summary
table circled here you can see how mild
these temperatures were leading up to
this the max temperature and the men
temperature and then we got down to
minus 10 degrees Fahrenheit which is
pretty significant and then if you
wanted to look at this from an hourly
standpoint you could query the hourly
data and you can see each hour how cold
it was and for how long the cold event
lasted because sometimes that also
weighs in on the level of damage that
you'll get on flower buds and vegetative
buds in woody plants another another way
that you can use the data in nua is to
look at rainfall data so I was giving a
talk in North Carolina to the Apple
Growers Association and I said to Jean
Clem straw who had set up a weather
instrument the year before I said hey
gene is there something that that
happened so I could go into the data up
pull that out and share with the
audience and we can talk about the use
of nua data for for something and he
said oh yeah we got eight inches of rain
in October when we were trying to
harvest our apples for
at it we couldn't get in there to in a
timely way to harvest our apples we had
to wait and wait it out so I went into
these are in monthly and that's another
thing I want to point out with this
slide is the data is in monthly tables
so in order to get data that spans like
the end of sep tember into the early
october you have to go to the month of
September in the month of October
obviously so this just shows the month
of October and you can see here the
daily data three inches of rain on one
day an inch each of the previous two
days and then if you look down the
hourly data you'll see that at some
point we were we were getting a half an
inch of rain a third of an inch of rain
a quarter of an inch of rain per hour
was falling and that is kind of what the
projection is that we're going to be
needing to expect in to plan for given
climate change we're going to have these
intense rainfall events and these
bizarre temperature events that may
impact our crops and this type of data
gives the grower the ability to document
that something really bad happened and
if they have crop insurance than they
can document that this significant event
happened and damaged their crop so now
I'm going to start our I'm going to go
over the crop management tools that are
in nua there are three that are really
knew a based I'll cover those towards
the end of this segment again we're
assessing risk we're getting decision
support and the primary ones we have in
nua that are that are currently
programed in as tools are crop load
management tool for apple and an
irrigation tool for apple and obviously
growing degree days
this is a tool that was created by Frank
Rossi and art de gaetano with the
Northeast Regional Climate Center so
this is their forecast suite of tools
and what I do then is I link to these
within nua these are not using nua data
they're using the cooperative weather
observer program data these are human
beings that are still observing weather
for the National Weather Service and
have been doing that since I believe the
1800s some sites so these data are then
used drive a suite of disease risk
models turpin weed development
irrigation information and heat stress
and frost some of these tools have been
built for apple frost risk aren't de
gaetano built these and these again
these maps if you click on these maps
they'll blow up but you can't at this
point zoom right in so the resolution of
these maps is not high resolution you
can't zoom right in on these locations
and you can select either Red Delicious
Empire or Macintosh with this tool
there's a great bud hardiness tool
that's experimental that art de gaetano
built and it is based on research out of
Washington State and the three varieties
that are available here are conquered
Cab Franc and Riesling and again there
are these maps that show the modified
hardiness temperature here but injury
potential obviously there's none right
now I access access this very recently
and then this is a chart showing the max
men and this is the hardiness line for
Concord and this is the lowest
temperature since july one map
this is a this is about as big as these
maps get so this is a about the highest
res that you'll get of this map on the
web right now but art also ardha gaetano
with Orton Earth and Atmospheric
Sciences he's also the director of the
Northeast Regional Climate Center built
this soil temperature algorithm for us
to estimate this we are going we're
planning hopefully to use these data in
a weed development model that Tony
detomaso Abby semen and I'm having a
senior moment is it Mike Ryan or Mark
Ryan I'm Matt thank you thank you are
potentially going to be developing so
and if you think about it soil
temperature and knowing soil temperature
could potentially be used for planting
date estimation for certain crops this
soil temperature map is available right
now so this is available if you go to
New Oh cornell.edu and go to crop
management it should be in that list if
it's not tell Betsy or Greg who are in
front of day know how to get ahold of me
so anyway um all right moving along so
now I'll show you the couple of tools
that are actually programmed in nua for
apple this is the apple
evapotranspiration model so it's
modeling the use of soil water by the
orchard so essentially you would select
the weather station this screen capture
was done last year before we had the
state selection in this utility you'd
select the date usually it defaults to
the current date hit continue and then
you're going to put the green tip date
will estimate that for you but if you
know that for your orchard block you
would get better results more accurate
results obviously if you enter that and
then you put your row spacing between
row spacing and the trees per acre you
can do either or obviously if you know
your trees per acre you don't really
have to do the row spacing and between
row space
and then this is a selection for the age
of the orchard I think it goes zero one
two three years and then mature and
you'll hit calculate I think the
calculate button is usually here under
this water balance and the table will
build the green row here is the green
tip date no it's the current date I'm
sorry wrong model the green row here is
the current date in blue are the past
dates and in brown are the forecast days
pushed out in this case I think they go
six to seven days into the future
rainfall right now we can't really get
if you've ever looked at a forecast it's
usually what are the chances of rain the
percent prediction it doesn't tell you
how much is going to fall so this
rainfall will inform how many gallons
per acre have fallen on the orchard how
much irrigation you've applied can be
entered here if you have your irrigation
record and then the daily water balance
in gallons per acre and the cumulative
water balance so the perspective is this
final number is the number that you need
to be concerned about if the tree has
drawn out ten thousand five hundred and
twenty six gallons per acre what you
need to do then is to look at the water
holding capacity of your soil obviously
and what they recommend is to start
irrigation if you're at if the tree is
drawn off ten percent of that water
holding capacity that's their earmark
benchmark target so what you would need
to do if you've got an irrigated orchard
you figure out how much water you're
putting out on your acres so the flow
rate of the emitters and the number of
emitters per acre and you can figure out
how much water you can put on
acre and then you use this calculation
to do that so that what these guys are
going to do so this model has been built
by Alan lactose research on Apple
physiology Terence Robinson's work with
extension and Terrance has a postdoc gel
me Lord Don and this is actually jammies
slide so johnny is now working on this
and they hope to develop an actual app
with this that where you can put in okay
emitters and soil type etc and will
improve this model anh nua accordingly
the other model that I wanted to walk
through our tool that I wanted to walk
through with you today is the apple
carbohydrate thinning model this model
is perhaps the biggest reason I think
why the network has grown so
significantly over the past few years
this model has revolutionized thinning
in orchards it's no longer okay I'm
going to put this much growth regulator
out and so there's an ounce of that I'm
going to put that in the tank and then
the grower porous himself or herself an
ounce of vodka shut that down and get on
there sprayer and they go out and they
spray that's not my joke i borrowed that
from dan donahue who works in the hudson
valley but it is I mean it just gives
you an idea it's almost like voodoo
thinning was like okay has it been
cloudy is it going to be hot what's
happening what are the trees like which
variety etcetera this model has been
phenomenal and again it's built on
research by Allen laakso and in tree
fruit physiology and work by a number of
horticulturalists in the Northeast that
have tested this over the years so what
you would do you first access the model
and this is just a screenshot showing
you how the map is first that shows up
you'd select the state the weather
station the date and hit continue then
the results tab will start to form and
here they're going to ask you to put in
a green tip date again we can estimate
that for you but it's always better if
you have your biological data in hand
the bloom date and then you hit
calculate and Apple carbohydrate results
tabulate and build so the thinning table
builds from me go back from the green
tip date here down very similar to the
irrigation table this green row this is
the current date that you just selected
the rows in blue above are the past
history and the rose and brown below are
what's forecast into the future and then
the thinning recommendation is in this
column so you're either going to
increase the thinner rate by a certain
amount decrease the thinner rate by a
certain amount or apply a standard rate
and below this the apple carbohydrate
balance charts and builds so what I
usually tell audiences is if you think
about it from the standpoint of being
female and having to carry a baby to
term which is very near and dear to my
heart because i had twins you have to
eat well you have to have a good
carbohydrate balance so if the tree is
starving and you put a thinner on it's
probably going to shed a lot of that
fruit right because it doesn't it
probably wants to drop some of that load
anyway so but it's never as simple as
that as you know because they're plants
and there's so much more complex than us
humans could ever think of being so if
the carbohydrate balance is in surplus
the opposite you would think would hold
true right it's going to take more
thinner to thin them off but the problem
is there's a lag there's a lag in in the
memory of the tree and a lag and all of
these processes within the tree so in
any case it's made thinning a lot less
of a I got to have that shot
before I can get on the tractor and put
that growth regulator out on my orchard
so some of the considerations that we
tell people going forward we have to
have good solar radiation data from the
weather station if it's out of range we
will silence the station because we
don't want the garbage in garbage out
thing we don't want people to be
accessing a model when the data going
into it is bad or could give them
erroneous results hard to thin varieties
are still going to be hard to thin and
obviously people need to use it within
the context of the thinning guidelines
in the area region state that they're in
so the next section of my talk I'm just
going to talk about how have we built
the capacity of nua so clearly the
biggest part in that or the piece of
that was partnering with the Northeast
Regional Climate Center they house our
database they help us with model
programming into the p.i design tools
that people are creating they help us
with some data quality control they
provide meteorological expertise and
guidance which we living in the
biological side of things we really
don't have a lot of and the nice thing
too is that they're interested in
agricultural applications of climate
data you know if they weren't interested
in that it would be a harder sell they
have also helped us with automated
reports that we wanted to generate to
send to people when we know that their
weather station is down and initially
when we implemented this I thought oh my
gosh everybody's going to be so mad
because we're you know hassling them
with these emails telling them their
station is down but the reality has been
I have gotten more compliments on that
then I've gotten anybody saying forget
it can you stop bugging me with this
it's just really been a win-win
situation these are the rain wise
incorporated weather stations and this
is the about weather stations menu
there's more to this menu now because we
put together more links for the
troubleshooting guide we have a how to
replace the battery things like that
these are solar powered this is the
solar panel that powers the instrument
this is a leaf wetness sensor now
they're mounted on the north side over
here under the tipping bucket this is
the radio antenna the radio the data is
radio signal transmitted to a computer
or a box inside the house or barn and we
either use the internet protocol the
file transfer protocol we're going to be
working on that API that I mentioned
earlier for one minute data and then
rain wise also has a few products in
their premium system I think they have a
frost alarm they've developed things
like that you can also send your data to
weather underground and other weather
service providers so weather stations
this is both really exciting for me and
almost overwhelming this charts only
through I believe July of 2015 I haven't
had a chance to upgrade this or update
this to include 2016 and the end of 2015
but in the last seven years we've seen
significant growth in the number of
weather stations connected to nua
because of partnering with all these
other states here this green is when the
New Jersey State Climatologist Nets
joined up with us the gray is the
University of Massachusetts which which
I must say we were zero funded in 2010
and I I think a big part of still being
here and being relevant is because at
that time Vermont and Massachusetts
wanted to join forces with us and and
they really helped us immensely in terms
of our funding base and keeping us
rolling and going so um for the
airport's for those of you who are who
are familiar with weather data enough to
know that the microclimate around that
weather station can have a significant
impact on the weather data we do have a
relative humidity correction factor for
our Airport data and we also have a leaf
wetness estimate for those locations
because typically meteorologists are not
collecting
that type of data they don't have those
types of sensors so this is our list of
partners it's exciting that this slide
is getting more and more full all the
time and I think probably the most
exciting thing for me is that the
Minnesota apple growers and the North
Carolina apple growers associations are
paying for statewide membership for all
of Minnesota and all of North Carolina
and I've asked them repeatedly are you
okay with that what if a vegetable
grower Steve put up a weather station
are you going to be like what and they
said no we're fine with that we're you
know that's what we want because we want
this network in our state so it's it's
pretty exciting dealing with apple
growers that for the most part have
shown a great deal of altruism through
nua it's it's been really quite
rewarding the new partners that we're
currently grooming so to speak enviro
weather which is a similar system to nua
that's based out of Michigan State
University we are now currently
receiving their data and looking at it
to make sure it's going to be compatible
with our new a database and how that
collaboration is going to look going
forward we're not sure because again
they have their own enviro weather and
we have new one how are we going to how
are we going to share our tools and and
whatnot so it's kind of going to be
exciting year looking to build that
there are Tuesday climatologist Nets one
is in North Carolina and one is in
Delaware that I've been in communication
with trying to enrich our network with
their data New York State mesonet has
put up I believe 125 or 150
state-of-the-art weather instruments all
across New York and these were in
response to Lee and Sandy that
devastated the coast and up into the
Hudson Valley so these are FEMA dollars
that are paying for this network to go
into New York so we're working with them
to see about getting that
set into nua we are partnering with
climate smart farming and seeing where
you know how can we collaborate with
them and we've just embarked on a
product I or a what is that you know a
beta test of getting data to the
University of Maine so that they can run
some of our data through their a grade
our models so that should be exciting
what are our stakeholder priorities so
top priority sustainable funding yes
sustainable funding I know many of you
know how important that is we'd like to
have a responsive web design so that if
you're on a smartphone Noah is going to
behave a little easier you won't be
pinching and pulling we'd love to have
more stations we have looked into using
the National Digital forecast database
of gridded data there are some issues
with that most notably leaf wetness for
all the plant pathology models looking
at developing apps alerts the growers
would very much like for us to remember
their planting dates and their green tip
dates and their bloom dates so they
don't have to have a little cheat sheet
and enter it every time that they use
the model more models more tools station
maintenance and troubleshooting we've
done quite a bit of that on that the
past two years and promoting awareness
which is why I'm here we held a planning
meeting so there's a state coordinator
for every state that's part of nua and
at the time we had our planning meeting
there were six state members of nua and
again they wanted responsive our
objectives when after our meeting we
came away with responsive web design a
set of premium products to build some
sustainable funding virtual stations
that's using that digital database and
wouldn't it be nice to have a developer
sandbox so Greg you could go in there
Apple Paul and youth open papal pollen
tube growth model here we go let's test
it out and so a developer could go in
set up some parameters put in some
language
it go and the tool would be created on
the fly and then you'd have this tool
that you could validate and change and
implement blueSky thinking I know I know
the people who know me are all like
Julie really okay all right so coming
down to earth so um having gotten older
and just having gotten a smartphone
which I used to hide my flip-flop
football when I was out talking to
growers because you know they knew i was
doing Nuala and I've been doing a lot of
other like digital computer stuff and so
I did I got a smartphone and Steve
valentino who was working for me he's
just gone on to grad school in you know
molecular biotechnology stuff you know
medicine that's very compelling area but
when he was working for me he was doing
all the troubleshooting weather station
maintenance stuff and he said well Julie
I don't even worry about if it opens
into another tab I just keep all the you
know on my browser on my phone I keep
all these things open and so then I have
all these tiles and I can just go up
down group and I went oh so what I did
was I did that and I took a picture of
my phone and so here you this is a
picture of my phone and so I've got the
urine nua is a blog that we set up
because i was told Julia gotta set up a
blog you've got to get a twitter account
he's got to do all his facebook okay and
so I've got the degree day calculator
the Apple disease models and the new a
homepage on my browser all the time and
you just hit reload and Mel reload
so anyway I mean for some of you it's
like yeah I knew that right so what have
you been doing in terms of just weather
data research so I mentioned about the
soil temperature estimates those this
year I believe they put out actual
sensors in specific soils they wanted to
use to validate that estimate so that's
ongoing there's some precipitation solar
radiation temperature and humidity data
quality control research that's ongoing
we've been trying to get funding to get
the gridded data developed and there's
another grant that's that's going to go
in that I'm part of so hopefully Noah
would benefit from that and then we did
some work on leaf wetness estimation and
found that an hour with relative
humidity above ninety percent would be a
good enough estimate we did you know so
that's kind of just a little ballpark of
what we're using right now and some of
the research that we've done so in terms
of model development there's the apple
pollen tube growth model this is another
thinning model essentially but it's a
value to organic producers who would be
applying lime sulfur Greg correct me if
I'm wrong okay so they'd be applying
lime sulfur too thin off blossoms so
they're gonna they're trying to kill the
blossom but you don't want to kill the
blossom unless the fruit has set or it's
at a vulnerable stage to be killed so
that's where I rely on people like
keithy odor at Virginia Tech and greg
peck to to inform this so we're excited
about this and we're hoping we might be
able to get some funding to develop this
model here in the near term Tony
detomaso and soil and crop Sciences I
mentioned is looking at a weed
management model betsy lamb whose in
this room got a grant from New York farm
viability Institute to develop woody
ornamental insect degree day tools and
the New York berry Growers Association
funded us
develops some very insect and disease
models and essentially you've got a wish
list of over 40 models maybe it's only
38 now maybe maybe we maybe we did two
of these this past year so just quickly
some impacts and outcomes so Noah is
transforming this weather data into
knowledge you know it's just it's
helping the grower farmers can share all
this weather data through the cloud and
we now have forecasts that are pushing
things out five days making it an actual
actual forecast so some of the things
growers are saying i use the newest site
almost every day early in the season the
orchard was largely scab free so apple
scab is a disease for the first time in
several years the manager relied heavily
on noah and to new jersey apple growers
reported the best thinning results ever
in 2015 using the apple carbohydrate
thinning model so better i p.m. reduce
pesticide use and yes people growth
regulators are pesticides reduce
pesticide use improved environmental
protection better crop management
improved crop quality improved yield
enhanced decision support so the chart
now you guys aren't really that
concerned about this chart this just
says yeah growers agree or strongly
agree that noah helps ipm reduce sprays
improve spray timing alert pest risk and
enhance I p.m. this was before we
launched our new website so this was
when even when we were on the clunky old
website today we're Bennett we're
experiencing over two million pageviews
per year now a page view is when the end
user is spending 30 minutes or more on a
page
back at seven growers reported they
could save on average and these are
primarily apple and grape growers on
average 19500 per year it costs and
prevent about a quarter of a million per
year in crop loss so again high-value
horticultural crops and when we asked
would you recommend nua to farmers
ninety-nine percent said yes they would
so Noah access to IPM decision support
an IPM is all about sustainable
management of pests using methods that
minimize environmental health and
economic risks so we're taking plant
disease epidemiology research insect
phenology research plant phenology
research and crop management research
and we're creating phenology models and
forecasts that benefit the end user
they're benefitting the grower I think
we're doing a pretty good job in fruit
and vegetables we could do better in
ornamentals betsy's lining the you know
yellow brick road on that one and you
know we'll see where the future is in
terms of field crops and livestock so I
think with that I will say thank you for
your attention and I'll take any
questions you might have
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu